what's up guys this may be one of my
favorite marvel movies since spider-man
no way home even though it's partly sony
and avengers end game this is one of the
best marvel movies we have seen in years
and i'm not going to spoil it for you
here are my thoughts on thor love and
thunder
[Music]
alright guys before we kick things off i
do want to let you know this will be a
spoiler free review so if you want
spoilers wait a few more days try not to
go on the internet though because you
don't want to spoil this movie there's a
lot of nuggets in there there's a lot of
easter eggs there's a lot of great
things in this and don't read the
internet for a few days because people
love to spoil things for you guys and
we're not gonna do that for you here
okay so i'm gonna give you my overall
thoughts on thor love and thunder the
standout actors in this and they're
gonna let it be at that and we want you
to watch this and enjoy it okay first
and foremost the soundtrack is one to
buy if you're a guns n roses fan you're
gonna absolutely love this movie you saw
you heard the song in the trailer
there's even more in this movie this is
an 80s rock anthem soundtrack you're
going to absolutely love it i'm buying
it as soon as it's available it's
probably available right now and i'm
going to buy it because i absolutely
love the songs in it so let's kick off
where we're at with this film this is
after thor's joined guardians of the
galaxy as we saw in endgame and they've
gone on a few adventures together but
thor's still trying to find himself and
he's got a sense of this an end game and
that kind of continues and he's sort of
like i think i'm at peace i think i know
who i am and cork he does a tremendous
job sort of narrating what's gone on
since we saw him last in endgame and
they kind of bring you up to speed and
taika watiti does this really well in
terms of getting you up to speed in
relatively you know no time flat i mean
the narration is hilarious there's a lot
of chuckles throughout the entire movie
and you get it right from the very
beginning chris hemsworth is absolutely
loving being this thor we saw this in
thor ragnarok and you were going to see
it continue right here in thor love and
thunder he loves being this character
especially when you have a writer and
director like taika wati who's directing
this and just scr describing the words
because it is funny as hell now this
movie does get a little bit corny at
times but it does maintain the balance
between being a little bit over the top
but also being very serious when it
needs to be anyway digressing let's go
back thor's sort of finding himself we
see him in his element with guardians of
the galaxy how this relationship sort of
unfolds and they do part ways quite
early on that's not a spoiler because as
you could tell by the trailers this is a
thor film through and through and the
the main storyline is really about gord
of god butcher as you saw in the
trailers and jane foster aka the mighty
thor that's where this film sort of lies
into it and you go from the very the
creepy the aspect the gore that
god butcher brings but also to the love
and to the romance and to the
um you we kind of know jane's story and
if you don't know it i'm not going to
spoil it for you but it is a very
touching story and they do it
beautifully they balance the crazy humor
which it does get really insane at times
to some of the more touchy more
heartfelt more grounded moments in the
film and i think only someone like taiko
attitu
can do this and i'm not a huge tyco a td
fan now i respect his work and some of
the things i think he does are fantastic
some of the things he does
it's a little bit over the top for me
but the balance in this film i knew was
going to be like this and he did it he
absolutely nailed it in this film
through and through okay
so um what did to expect if you are do
you know flash gordon from the 1980s
well you're gonna get a lot of that kind
of vibe in this film through the very
beginning a lot of bright colors a lot
of vibrancy a lot of neon colors it is a
1980s flashback film but of course with
2022 cgi and marvel and all that great
stuff involved with it so it is a kind
of a hark back to an era that i mean i
grew up with and i think some of you
probably grown up with it as well we
love this era it's big hair it's big
bands it's guitars it's drums it's
bright lights it's color that's what
this film is all about
but when it does become serious when it
does become horrific when it does become
dark
he also brings that into the mix one of
the things i like about this film is you
do get a sense of how gore became gore
the god butcher and christian bale
by the way is absolutely phenomenal in
this role i know i read a review earlier
on and you probably have read it as well
where tycho atd said this is one of the
best villains that he's seen on in the
marvel cinematic universe and i tend to
agree i think
christian bell really brought it in a
way that
gives gore a multi-dimensional aspect to
his character we saw this with um
josh brolin when he did
uh thanos and you're seeing that also
with gore the god butcher which i think
is great because a lot of the the
the villains in some of these marvel
movies can be a little bit too
dimensional at times
but when you have the right actor you
have the right writers and the right
director
it can come out beautifully and it does
in this film and without christian bale
being in this role i don't think it
works as well making gore the god
butcher this
type of character that kind of drives
the all the other characters motivations
in this and it's really interesting how
he does it and it's beautiful to watch
so christian bill is a standout in this
film let's talk about some of the other
actors that have stood out in this
russell crowe as zeus holy is he
hilarious he is funny as hell in this
you could tell he led a blast playing
zeus i mean this film is a little bit
over the top and he brings it in a way
which is spectacular by the way don't
want to give anything away with those
two post credits scenes and
uh
maybe there's something on zeus or not
zeus i'm not going to say but there is
something you definitely want to stick
around for but russell crowe is funny in
this movie he's hilarious
but
something about the zeus
may by the end of this film you're going
to be going
i was expecting that i was not expecting
zeus to go this way just putting that
out there okay next let's talk about
tessa thompson as valkyrie or king
valkyrie she's fantastic in the role
honestly um
she's great she doesn't have a lot to do
in this film because this film is
primarily around jane foster and thor
and their relationship with their past
relationship and where they're at now
but she is there in a supporting role
she does help out a lot of ways in terms
of pushing the storyline forward and her
character does have a lot it does have
some
consequential moments in this film
but she's not a main part of this
storyline so just keep that in mind if
you're a tessa thompson fan but she does
a great job in it okay let's talk about
korg for a second taika watiti who is
sort of the narrator of this uh movie
sort of uh the voice for thor as he goes
through his journeys that you know and
we kind of catch up to him up to speed
from the very beginning of it and
through different parts of this film as
well he's great in it i mean he adds a
nice humor element to things when he
needs to be um he doesn't overdo it now
i like for example
when i watched light year and taika what
tv was in it was in that as well i felt
his character was a little bit kept
repeating the same kind of jokes and the
same kind of things over and over again
and it lost its
flare lost its humor along the way
he knows when to bring korg back and he
knows when to let korg be
and he does it really well in this film
and korg is a very very uh he's an
integral part of this you're going to
really enjoy watching him if you if you
like thor if you like korg and ragnarok
you're going to really like him in love
and thunder moving on let's talk about
chris hemsworth if you're worried this
was going to be
a film that's going to be centered
around valkyrie or jane foster and thor
was going to be sidelined in his own
film this is not the case this is chris
hemsworth through and through and you
can tell he absolutely loves being thor
this guy is really enjoys this character
he you can see that he loves the
evolution of thor he loves where this
character's going and he digs in to the
humor but he also digs into the heart
and to the soul of this movie into a
very big way and i think there's a nice
change in door we see from the very
beginning to where we end and i think
taiko ati knew where to go with this
character and he brings it in a way that
i feel personally this is better than
his performance in thor ragnarok i
really like this film actually better
than ragnarok
as a whole this is my favorite thor film
to date um
he really is fantastic in this and god
is he buffed he is jacked in this film
absolutely jacked but uh he's great he's
he's i mean you're gonna watch this with
a new appreciation of hemsworth after
watching love and thunder okay
and now let's get down
to natalie portman as jane foster um
if you read the comic books you kind of
know her storyline already if you
haven't read it i'm not going to give
anything away she plays mighty thor in
this film
and you could you could understand why
she wanted to come back for this movie
because you know in the first thor and
then and you know dark world there
really wasn't much for her to do so much
in that in those films per se
this is a very meaty role for her and um
it's a very touching very heartfelt role
it's great i mean she looks fantastic
she she built herself up to look amazing
as mighty thor she put a lot of hard
work into it and it pays off and she's a
really good superhero she's a really
good superhero and i'll tell you what i
mean i i mean not gonna give away what
happens to her character in this but uh
man she really brought it you could tell
that she brought her a game to the
marvel cinematic universe i mean she's
always a fantastic actress but she
really brought it in a way where she
embraced the humor but she also embraced
the other side and she embraced that
heroism where by the end of this film
you are rooting for mighty thor
as much as you're rooting for thor
and
taika does an amazing job of balancing
it and really bringing it into the fold
and
how they interact with each other in a
way that is uh
it's really really touching you guys are
gonna really really enjoy this i keep
saying that but it is true this is a
fantastic film it is my favorite thor
film uh thus far
there's a lot of cameos in this movie
there's a lot of surprises there's a lot
of easter eggs and you're going to hear
all about these in the coming days from
a lot of reviewers out there and you're
going to see some things on twitter and
probably on youtube as people like to
record something put on there
i'm going to say if you are a big marvel
fan
don't just stay offline for a couple
days if you want to watch this review
fine i'm keeping it spoiler free but
stay off twitter stay off the other
youtube videos that could pop online
that just show clips of movies because
you want to really embrace this because
it is
it has all the elements of a great story
humor heart action
drama
horror
fear
i mean there's so many elements in this
film that he packed it in
that i'm like man probably one of my
favorite marvel movies
we have seen
in the last couple of years yes better
than chongqi for me better than a doctor
strange
to
man i mean better than eternals
this is a fantastic movie and you guys
are gonna walk out applauding like the
audience did when we watched it and you
could probably want to go back and see
it again anyway those are my thoughts on
thor love and thunder let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
by the way there's two post credits
scenes so stay around for those one
pretty much right after the first rule
of credits and then after to at the very
end so stick around for those they're
both really good with that guys follow
us on facebook subscribe to the channel
like this video we got a lot more great
content coming your way here on geek
culture with that take care stay safe
and i will chat to you soon bye
[Music]
you